[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con esta semana
canadá acogió la conferencia
internacional de donantes en solidaridad
con los refugiados inmigrantes
venezolanos en colaboración con la acnur
y la organización internacional para las
migraciones para hablar de este tema nos
acompaña a karina gaut ministra de
desarrollo internacional de canadá y
diputada federal de burlington
gracias por acompañarnos el mayor
resultado de la conferencia
internacional de donantes que canadá
acogió fue la promesa de más de 1500
millones de dólares estadounidenses para
ayudar a los migrantes venezolanos
quienes aportan este dinero y hacia
dónde va dirigido
claro pues muchas gracias por tenerme y
este fue recaudado por los donantes
usted la mayoría por los eeuu de la
unión europea a españa y canadá pero
fueron más de 30 33 donar donantes y va
dirigido a los países receptores de
emigrantes venezolanos en la región como
usted sabe muy bien hay 17 países en las
américas que han recibido migrantes
buenos son planos a la mayoría se
encuentran en colombia perú ecuador
entonces va a ir dirigido a esos países
y para apoyar a los migrantes refugiados
venezolanos usted justamente mencionaba
ecuador como uno de los países que ha
recibido a los migrantes y en el evento
el gobierno de esta nación prometió una
figura similar a la que tiene
para regularizar de cierta forma a los
migrantes venezolanos que viven allí en
qué consiste la iniciativa al menos por
lo que se pudo hablar en la conferencia
pues este lo que nosotros esperamos es
que esa ese apoyo va dirigido a asegurar
que los migrantes y los refugiados
reciben acceso a los servicios como los
de salud la asistencia este de comida la
esté asistirá a la educación y también
encontrar trabajo entonces nosotros y
con este alto comisionado del acnur
estamos apoyando para que los países que
reciben los venezolanos pueden
regularizar su estatus también entonces
estamos muy la bienvenida a los países
que están en este trayectoria bueno con
esta iniciativa quiero preguntarle
también de dónde surgió la idea de
realizar esta conferencia
pues la conferencia hubo tomó el lugar
por primera vez el año pasado es de las
atracciones fueron la unión europea y
españa y canadá decidió de hacerlo este
año para para seguir con con el momento
porque o sea esa es una de las crisis
más grandes del mundo es el segundo más
importante desplazamiento en el mundo y
es la mayor crisis que ha enfrentado en
las américas entonces también queremos
que el mundo de lo que está pasando en
el hemisferio y este fue el crisis menos
ha financiado entonces queríamos
realmente aumentar la visibilidad de la
crisis y demostrar la solidaridad tanto
con los países receptores que con los
venezolanos migrantes ellos mismos el
gobierno de venezuela respondió diciendo
que la iniciativa que se acordó en la
conferencia era una farsa mediática que
promovía una propaganda política
antivenezolana que respondería a usted
al respecto
pues mira la conferencia no fue nada
política realmente fue este enfocado en
la crisis humanitaria sabemos los hechos
hay 5.6 millones de venezolanos que han
salido de su país que se encuentran
actualmente en el hemisferio en países
receptores que necesitan ayuda y también
hay 7 millones de personas dentro de
venezuela misma que necesitan ayuda y
asistencia humanitaria
eso no fue algo política sino fue un
enfoque hay un enfoque total sobre el
apoyo humanitaria que han que necesitan
de esas personas y para apoyarlos
bueno pues una de las críticas de
nicolás módulo es que no se conoce el
destino de los 2800 millones de dólares
que se han recaudado hasta ahora cómo se
invirtió ese dinero le pido que me
responda muy brevemente
pues de hecho nosotros hemos hecho una
recopilación de ese dinero y vamos a
lanzar un informe para eso pero va
dirigido a los países receptores para
que ellos pueden proveer los servicios
también a las organizaciones este de
sociedad civil que dan servicios directo
a los migrantes señora gaby a usted
muchísimas gracias por su análisis y a
ustedes por acompañarnos en cinco
minutos con continúen con nosotros en
france 24
[Música]